17 ça se faisait ça fait as-tu membres
[Musique]
alors on va maintenant justement parler
des sceaux est ma famille a besoin d
aide l'émission diffusée sur nrj12
pascal a pour mission de venir en aide
amandine amandine mais vous allez voir
que dès son arrivée la jeune fille
devient complètement incontrôlable là
c'est mon kiff ça tous les dimanches
soirs regardez croyez pas que c'est
sébastien on verra quelle sera la taille
je pas peur mais bon voire semaines on
n'a pas parlé de poster peur qu'il
arrive
et derrière son zinc en train de
regarder je pense qu'il va bouillir qui
veut dire en face
[Musique]
paul simon
pas de quoi non pour mieux te parler moi
mais moi bien voilà donc c'était chaud
c'était chaud et juste on a vu aussi que
calcul mental voilà amandine c'était pas
ça non pas six mais voilà c'était pas ça
spécial et vous allez voir même pascal
n'en revient pas mais après ça se finit
bien comme d'habitude regarder tout ça
regarde c'est ta souffrance et imagine
donc écoute bien 14 kg
[Musique]
plus 10 kilos ça fait quand même
14 kg + 10 kg sait trop combien
quatorze +10 prends ton temps mancka
très bien 24 +6 28,4 +6 ma cocotte
réfléchi quand même 30
oui multiplé par 2,30 +30 pas son sens
oui alors et matthew ten kate impôts là
tu oui parce que je suis un petit peu
gêné par la tnt ça va pas être la
poubelle de dire tiens c'est vrai que
j'ai pu beaucoup d'argent la télé mais
pascal ceaux tonnes ce qui est plus sur
la chaîne me disait tout ce qui passe le
dimanche soir sur sur nrj12 et j'ai rien
contre cette chaîne j'adore ont 5 ans
minimum 5 ans aussi y avoir il ya un
moment fort la donc cédé roddick des
rona webroot c'est vrai que ça fait
toujours du bien pour le convoi vous
étiez au calcul mental ça peut aller
allez-y 14 plus 13 14 13 20
je vais y aller c'est intéressant on est
temps de passer à la barre des 30 noms
oui et c'est pas le juste prix à 14 e +
13 c - 28 17 16 plus 17
alors je dois à j'ai compris ton truc
c'est quoi alors ça fait treize les
trois plus un je dirais ça fait ça je
peux 17 se faisait seize ça fait du
bruit
[Rires]
sais tu combien 16 17 alors à temps
allez allez attention je t'aurais dit
sourdis tu as 10-13 avant plus du seces
+17 cesse plus 17 17 10 seront rabotées
habitants d'un autre fait pourquoi
[Musique]
dire que tu peux lui mettre que tu veux
ce son chèque
il s'en fout mais tu peux lui mettre
n'importe quoi
[Musique]